my colleague Josephine Chang has
corralled another expert or two in the
halls of the conference center she is
working the hallways here checking with
folks Josephine that's right I have
moved to the hallway because this is a
prime spot for reaching out literally
reaching out to researchers and guess
who I've reached out to this is Ed
Lisowski from the University of
Washington welcome are there I know that
you have worked with big data and sort
of data intensive discovery for a long
time what is what is changing that is
making it more and more importance so
what's changing is there's the world of
sensors now right the sort of
relentlessly decreasing cost of centers
and met more and more so whether it's
the density of sensors in a gene
sequencing machine or a telescope or
there were sensors in roads and bridges
and buildings in your environment there
more of them and field after field after
field that used to be data poor is data
rich and your challenge now is not
getting the data it's extracting
knowledge from the data and figuring out
what to do with it Eric orbits at
Microsoft Research calls that data to
knowledge to action and that's what we
have to do for science and for every
field finding out what's important
finding the needle in the haystack
alright a credit card fraud detection is
an example but finding events in physics
experiments as another example so
working we're working with astronomers
and oceanographers and biologists and
social scientists if you think about the
social sciences if you want to study the
formation and evolution and dissolution
of social cliques used to pay a bunch of
students six bucks an hour to
participate in a focus group and now
they are you more than that now they
need a billion users worth of facebook
data hi so so the world is changing for
everybody I've heard you say this a term
that if you are not part of the
steamroller you're part of the road
which is a very funny image but what
what do you mean in this content well
it's actually a joke on my website about
my personal behavior which is rolling
relentlessly forward despite bureaucrats
in the way oh I see I thought you made
you'd have to deal with change or else
it'll it'll a part of it as well yes so
you're talking about many disciplines
that are involved in this this idea of
mining rich data applies to so many
things in them absolutely right and many
things in individuals lives as well as
scientists lie
but my focus at the university is
bringing these techniques of data
intensive discovery to a wide range of
fields and also moving these techniques
for words so it has a lot in common with
Microsoft Research when you're trying to
do great research and you try and do the
translational work in which you make
sure that that work is a value at MSR
it's through Microsoft products for
example in my world it's through taking
these advances in data intensive
discovery techniques whether it's
visualization or machine learning and
putting them to work for lots of people
and lots of deals well that is very
important work thank you so much for
talking with us about you and great to
be here all right thank you and you know
what else snagged another one right
behind ed this is Liz Gerber from
Northwestern University hi honey thank
you I know that you are very interested
in design and in particular the sort of
human interaction between you know
humans and technology why why your
interest in that oh I I'm passionate
about and have been since a little kid
because if you don't have designs that
people want to use their just designs on
the shelf yeah it's that simple right if
people don't want to use them they won't
be used and they're just ideas and I
know that your research has to do with
sort of collective intelligence in order
so bringing people together for
crowdfunding crowdsourcing trellis yes I
see a huge opportunity to leverage and
tap into the resources of the general
public to actually generate new ideas
and I think that historically the
innovation process has been locked
within large companies and I think
there's an amazing opportunity right now
with social media and communication
technologies to expand participation so
can you give us an example of how it
works and also whether that has resulted
in a better product sure so there's
examples in every possible domain of in
the domain of computer games let's say a
lot of designers are now saying you know
what I'm not gonna I'm not going to work
with in a big company i'm actually going
to design the game myself and i'm going
to go onto a platform like kickstarter
and actually raise the money for it and
then distribute the product directly to
my consumers and then curiously the
companies are coming around and saying
and maybe now we'll help you expand that
so there's this really interesting new
balance in relationship between the
designer the creator and in the
corporation is there an example of a
product would was vastly improved
because of that process oh yes many many
one was a recent SmartWatch that came
out it's a great story because it was a
watch that was put out and if they
actually the designer initially tried to
sell it to a company and the company
said no we're not interested and then
they went to again on a crowdfunding
platform to put out the product and
people gave them all sorts of ideas for
improvement they said here's my thirty
dollars and here's how I think you
should make it better so they not only
got money they also got feedback for
improving the idea and then when they
had the money they distributed the
product and they had this large consumer
base this is a case in which the company
then came back and said nothing they'll
buy your product yeah on second thought
i'm exid is what is that smart one
that's the pebble watch wow so
interesting and I love your motto which
is instead of doing do it yourself its
design it together is that sort of the
trend of the future I think that's the
trend of the future is it's a nude it's
a new world of designing it together in
technology social computing allows us to
be able to do that much more efficiently
and effectively than before that's great
interesting research thank you so much
less gear romania thank you and
hopefully all that is going to mean
better products for us and users in the
end